well many ukrainian teenagers have fled
to germany now they're attending special
classes to help them get used to life in
exile but as our next report shows that
life is still far from normal
[Music]
music class is also an opportunity to
relax a little
these children from ukraine fled the
country when war broke out some of them
with their families some alone
they've been attending this berlin
school for four months now
and they're beginning to get the hang of
the german language
okay
after lincoln's
luckily most of them can already speak
some english
often they have to translate for family
members at government offices or even
look for accommodation all at the age of
14.
the family have a big problem to find
a flat yeah it was too hard
uh we
uh
move forward
from one flat to the other and we can't
find
one
where we can stay alone time
and there is a problem with the flats
and also the money that
like no one is working because my mother
doesn't know the language yet and
of course she's learning about
how she can like pay for our living and
other stuff like this
a huge plus is that teacher abella
wesselai has a social worker on hand to
help
she's fully aware that the pressure on
these teens is immense
the stresses they face in their private
lives means many find it hard to
concentrate in class
tough going it's not easy for them it
would be a lie to say that their
transition into the mainstream school
system will be easy it won't
but it's manageable and we're here to
support them
will they stay in germany long term
the students are caught between two
worlds mornings german school in the
afternoons most of them have online
classes with their ukrainian teachers
it's a busy schedule and they don't have
much spare time to get to know germany
better
many of the students are taking online
classes as well
but unfortunately neither system works
very well
a little in german a little in ukrainian
they just can't learn that quickly
the teachers here want to help the
students come away with the high school
qualification
even if they leave germany in the future
at least they can have something to take
with them